bullet cat podcast special guest in here
uh i got my brother ricky hyde in here
rick hyde yeah ricky plate's too big now
i'm gonna let you introduce we got a
newcomer you already know you got damp
in the building dap that's my brother
dap right here man straight out of
philly man yeah certainly fine as dapper
shout out to the big bsf man shout out
to my tony de niro jake uh let's let's
do it man yo
play a beat man let's get to it
oh yeah
we're going to philly with it yeah play
2 out shut out the young girl
everywhere run that up
be yourself what up
said money ain't buying happy but it's
soft in the tears sipping mimosas on the
yacht to spit ball on ideas see i'm
still packing shows and match making my
goals make 20 mil and pay the way for my
goal just so you know still seeing too
that haters get the space they deserve
pulling up few hours later cause the
space was reserved crab legs with heavy
butter getting charged by the weight and
the lobster is half alive is crawling
off of the plate see the ones talking
the most is usually doing the least the
condo 5k a month we keep renewing the
least and man my two newest chicks worth
two million a piece they eat quiche and
use words like felice
okay
yeah
it's ricky
we catch this joint man
look
since place two dropped every move gotta
expand my wealth even alan know i'm
worth a half a man myself boy i'm hotter
than dubai in the middle would you lie i
need rappers stay alive like the
clippers need kawhi paul george's voice
you [ __ ] better pass it you put me in
a dis song i put you in a casket i hear
you [ __ ] stretching out the punches
like elastic see a shot take a shot
[ __ ] i'm reggie jackson pocket's full
of slushes got me moving cautious glock
23 protect the pocket dion dawkins i
don't like [ __ ] [ __ ] always
talking you the type to put your trust
into it like the dolphins trick dawson i
used to want to be a doctor then i
started rapping i make a neurosurgeon
salary i drop a classic the place series
need a three i'm going for the hat trick
missy elliot how are you [ __ ] rapping
backwards lazy susan or honeybacky you
got pressure matching you wanna book me
it's 11 rackies any paperwork just
telling facts and all inquiries just
make it make sense like christina mackey
no comparison you see the statues i used
to be an athlete now i'm just smoking
out the p relaxing i might go do me a
little trip to ask me just to hit the
cabins i'm always open like the kitchen
cabins my [ __ ] bad enough to nut inside
and start a family she helped me on my
last leg so i call her baby she watch me
get it off the glass like i marcus can
be i had 12 in a frenzy just like i'm
jalen ramsey a true story about grams
you'll probably never get a grammy you
ain't [ __ ] with black soprano family
[ __ ]
ricky
you ain't [ __ ] with black soprano fan
nah
i just want to shout out to some of the
those are some of the hardest
very very
timely sports bars i've heard in a lot
of
giving now that the 12 uh jalen rams
come on yeah
yeah come on man big bsf big bsf man
april the new album in april oh yeah
yeah yeah long live dj shape what's
going on
april hey i know you just watched the
crazy freestyle appreciate you watching
make sure you subscribe and make sure
you show some love to our folks at lrg
clothing man listen
i've been [ __ ] with lrg since i was
in high school and they are still doing
their [ __ ] thing all right and i got
something special for you 30 off
your next order at lrg all you got to do
is use the keyword and by keyword i mean
promo code
use the promo code kev30 that's
kev30 we're gonna put the website right
there you see it right there
l dash r
g dot com all right we'll put the
website right there cook put the website
right there
save you 30 off one more time use that
promo code kev 30 on lrg's website for
your chance well not your chance you'll
actually get 30 off it's not like it's a
[ __ ] contest just use the code and
you got it alright shout out to lrg